[Music]
i'm rex woodbury one of the view from
the top
student leaders on behalf of the
leadership team thank you for joining us
today
we're excited to be able to bring an
outstanding diverse slate of speakers to
stanford this year
to inspire all of us as future leaders
and now it's my pleasure to welcome dean
levin to introduce our guest
today welcome to view from the top
today i'm delighted to introduce tony
shu
mba class of 2013 the co-founder and the
ceo of doordash
it's a special pleasure to have tony
given the history and close connection
that he
and doordash have with the gsb i know
we've all developed an
even deeper appreciation of tony in his
company over the last 12 months
and i will say that in the levin family
i think his reputation
peaked just after my son ben's 13th
birthday
in november in december so ben received
a bunch of gift cards
from amazon and nike and he came to me
after his birthday and he said
i want to cash these in and i said why
you love amazon and nike and he said yes
but i want to swap them for a doordash
gift card
so we're all looking forward to hearing
from tony in today's conversation with
our own
joy wong mba class of 2021 thank you
tony for joining us
it is really wonderful to have you at
the virtual gsb
it's always really exciting to have an
alum join us
especially for a product that all of us
are so familiar with
that's good to hear yeah my guess is a
lot of audience dialing in
are watching this interview with food
they got from doordash right now
send me feedback at any point in time
i'm just tony at doordash.com
be careful you wish for tony i know
people are probably really eager to hear
about all the lessons you learned from
the gsb
so this might come as a bit of a
surprise for some of the mba students
but you once said that more things
growing up
as a kid prepare you to start a business
than anything else could you tell us
more about that
sure i i think it's really hard to you
know follow
maybe a curricula or some you know
prescribed set of steps to do something
that has very high variance obviously
when we started the company
out of my apartment off campus we
weren't thinking about what doordash
would look like seven eight years
later and and i think that's really what
starting a company really is and so
when i think there's lots of variants
and you're learning pretty much on the
fly
a new job every week in the beginning
later on maybe every month every six
months you really have to
you know find other maybe first
principles
that uh have accumulated in other parts
of your life
uh to really get you over the hump at
times and so you know for me growing up
as a kid
um when i came to this country with my
parents when i was very young i was five
years old we emigrated here from china
um you know mom and dad really came here
to make a better life for me and
for dad that meant going to school
getting his phd
and working a job actually um at a
restaurant on campus at the university
of illinois
for my mom who meant working three jobs
a day for the first 12 years
of her journey here and so i didn't see
them that often and so most of my
time was pretty unstructured and
i think as a result that unstructured
time
was what was able to uh obviously i
wasn't thinking about becoming an
entrepreneur when i was five years old
nor did i ever think what would happen
from my unstructured time but i think
some of the benefits really came
um from trialing a bunch of new things
and i think that
it's that time that really uh um you
know taught me a lot of lessons
about how do you learn things for the
first time um you know for me that meant
language
um that meant you know earning income to
buy nintendo
that meant many small things but when i
put them together those are some of the
lessons that i remember most
you mentioned that your family moved
from china to illinois when you're young
and little did you know you would soon
move again this time
from illinois to san jose and when you
got to san jose
one of your teachers told you that you
were two years behind your class
and in response you said that you would
become the valedictorian
of your class which you did what was
going through your mind when you said
that to your teacher
i don't know what probably went through
my head obviously i wasn't thinking that
clearly
when that comment came out because in
some ways he absolutely was right i was
behind
you know i grew up in um i grew up in a
community in illinois that prioritized
um other things beyond the classroom a
lot of it was in
sports and uh that taught me a lot you
know playing basketball for instance was
really how i
one of the main ways in which i learned
english but when i
came to san jose in high school or to
finish high school
i really was in a world of culture shock
um the bay area i later found out
is a very competitive area especially in
the classroom
um and and you know the school i went to
i i think students were studying you
know all the time
in during the school day after hours um
i had not really done my homework prior
you know when i when i was growing up so
i i was um
you know i probably didn't have the
model preparation
uh for coming into school and
but i think one thing um that i've
always uh
really believed about um you know both
my family as well as
you know many of the different um moves
i've made as a kid
because i moved a lot actually even when
i was in illinois different schools
things like this
is really that i
i had gained confidence even by then
that i could survive in new environments
i you know whether that meant making
friends whether it meant becoming a
chameleon
and learning maybe what it was that was
um
i guess important to that community um
and so i had confidence that
uh even though i i didn't really study
you know versus
some of my peers at that time that if i
kind of really put my mind to it
and and maybe took all the attention i
used to spend you know maybe playing
sports
but putting it towards the classroom
that um
i i i could actually be successful so
that's probably what i was thinking
i doubt any of that you know was what
was in my mind when the comments flipped
out
but it you know ultimately it worked out
it's truly impressive to see
that you took a lot of what other people
might see as obstacles in stride
and then and then built this drive that
that we
will also see in the story of how you
created doordash
and tony you were mentioning that your
mom
um and your dad had a lot of influence
on you as a child and
your mom really is an entrepreneur and
she opened her small businesses
subsequently that you
had worked in um so it seems like they
really
instilled this entrepreneurial spirit in
you with their own examples
i'm curious how did that shape the type
of business that you then wanted to
create
yeah i mean i mean i i really don't
think this is a story you can tell um
you know back then looking forward it's
only a story maybe you can connect the
dots looking backward
you know for me my parents um you know
journey really is the classic immigrant
story
um and uh you know many folks
i i think can appreciate coming into
this country
with without much you know my parents
came here with maybe 200 in the bank
and it was you know we're going to make
it or not
situation there wasn't really much of an
in-between road but i think when you
have nothing to lose
um you also have a lot of upside as a
result
and um and i think that that was
probably one of the earliest lessons i
took
where i think on one hand for me it was
just hanging out with my mom that was
really what i was doing when i was
working inside of her restaurant or
washing dishes alongside her and things
like that but on the other hand i
learned that
you know this is the way that you can
earn your way
into better things you know for me it's
why you know it's why i worked at a
really young age it was to save up
enough money to buy nintendo to buy the
games that came within
nintendo so i'm not talking about big
things per se but that's that's what i
you know thought a lot about as a kid
it's why i decided to mow lawns
you know when i was nine years old and
and you know effectively knock on doors
so that i can
um you know create different shapes
because if you cut grass at different
heights that's how you can create
different shapes
and in places like illinois where
there's a lot of land there's a lot of
grass you can cut
which means that you can earn your way
to more video games and so you know i
think that
these are small things when i look
backwards and i think what it taught me
was that um if you put your mind to
whichever new thing it is um
and you maybe either because of reality
or because of um putting yourself in
that frame of mind
think that you have nothing to lose
there's there's a lot of upside
yeah and we were just talking about how
this young enterprising side view and i
thought that's a great segue into
how you later then also learned about
other aspects of
entrepreneurship at the gsb and i know
many
of us in this audience are taking
startup garage right now
which is famously the class where you
started doordash um back then was still
paulo autodelivery.com
and true to this lean startup mvpe
methodology
you and your co-founders were really
scrappy at the beginning
um one example that i really loved was
how you guys
tracked drivers with the find my friends
function on the iphone instead of
building out a very sophistic
sophisticated back-end technology for it
what were some lessons that you learned
from that class that stuck with you
yeah well i think the first lesson that
we learned is um
you know what's the uh what's ultimately
the
um almost overly simplified problem that
you're trying to solve
and and um and
if you can ask yourself that question
very crisply i think that's a very
clarifying way to really test ideas very
very quickly you know i think one of the
you know um earliest uh
things that made doordash i think a
fast-moving place was that
we always try to simplify the question
we were trying to solve we knew for
example that if we wanted to ultimately
build last mile delivery
that's way too big of an endeavor for
you know just four of us inside of a
classroom or inside of my apartment
right
and so instead we asked ourselves you
know
three questions we asked ourselves you
know is is this a service that
students or people customers would
actually want and would they actually
pay for
it um and and i believe at the time we
said you know would they pay six dollars
for it
um is this a service that restaurants
would actually pay for and i think at
the time
you know we're trying to remember this
is
you know in 2012 maybe the startup
garage class that we took so
almost eight years ago i think it was
like 15 or something like that would
restaurants
and would drivers um you know want this
job enough to earn
uh to to you know see it as a an
opportunity to work
and and that was it those were the three
questions that we were trying to answer
and i i think the first lesson
again is to really simplify what you're
trying to do because
i think often times when you try to
solve a really hard problem
um as the first uh i guess quote-unquote
go to market to test your ideas
um you might you might not even know
um what it is that you're actually
trying to solve and then the second
thing is
just that you learn by doing you know i
think none of us really had a background
in
logistics or delivery we learned by
doing deliveries we learned by
you know working alongside restaurant
tours we learned
by um
[Music]
doing customer service and and when i
think of you know
that's kind of what we were doing when
we were in startup garage
i i don't necessarily know if we like
like
link those two ideas when we're doing it
but but that's but
but the learning by doing and the
simplifying the question that you're
trying to solve
i think we're pretty important
principles yeah i think it's really
interesting because they're almost a
contrast where you're trying to really
simplify but also
at the same time you want to embrace the
complexity of all the operations that is
entailed in the business
and i like to expand on the second point
a bit too um
because like you mentioned um the four
of you drove
as drivers for fedex and dominoes to
learn about how deliberate works
um and and you drove all the delivery
for doordash in the in the first year
it's a year and a half
um you have now synthesized this into a
core principle for doordash
that you call getting to the lowest
level of detail
could you help us first understand what
this principle means
yeah so i you know i um
i i mentioned that we didn't really we
weren't really students
or or we weren't really experts in
logistics per se so we had to be
students of it and and the only way we
thought we could be students was by
actually doing the work
and so when we started doing deliveries
we started noticing that
um wow um some restaurants are really
really
fast and efficient and other restaurants
take a little bit longer
um some dashers the drivers on our
platform
are really fast and accurate
and and others are are are not as much
um some customers uh
really seem to care about uh a
certain type of salad for example um
versus
versus um you know um what others may
just consider to be a mundane meal
and and you start
realizing that hopefully to bring
something to you something especially
that perishes
in minutes whether it's ice cream
melting or pizzas getting cold
and doing that over and over again
consistently because
you know this is something that you
don't really get any points for the
you know first set of deliveries that
you got right if you got the current one
wrong
that tends to be what customers remember
there's a lot of steps you know we
ultimately identified about 20 steps
um in the process and and
it really came from you know doing the
work
and and when problems arose it classic
asking five why's
um you know analysis to get to the
lowest branch of what what the actual
problem is because most of the time what
we realized was
in something that seems as quote unquote
easy or mundane as delivery
[Music]
if you're at the surface level you're
never going to actually
realize what that problems are they're
always hidden somewhere um
and and maybe a restaurant is
you know delayed one day actually
because someone didn't show up to work
but you never would guess that
um if you're just looking at the data of
how long it takes them to prepare
something for example that would never
probably register
on your dashboard so operating at the
lowest level of detail
is pretty much trying to find your way
to the right
problem and it almost never is at the
surface
that's really interesting insight and
i'm curious once
you have learned this how do you then
impart this
on the employees and um to make sure
that this principle
actually makes the company more
successful
yeah i i don't think it's you know
necessarily one mechanism
or or or two mechanisms um but it's
something extremely over
the years that i would say lots of great
people at the company have developed
um and kind of put together different
things that we do you know one of the
things that that
we found effective is is really writing
things down doordash has a
pretty strong writing culture you know
we tend to start meetings by reading
documents that people have written
and and really these documents are you
could think of them almost as hypothesis
trees almost
where we're guessing what the problem is
and we're trying to get to the lowest
level
uh branch and to really understand and
we're really looking for the
disconfirming evidence
to try to see whether or not we're just
confirming our own bias or actually you
know we're on the right path to seeing
what the
the right problems are um i would say
you know other mechanisms um that that
doordash have found to be
maybe um helpful in this endeavor is
to actually do the work so
this is why for instance um we have
everyone at the company do deliveries
once a month or do customer service
once a month i do customer service
actually every day
because you know sometimes it's really
hard just looking at the data to get to
the um
to the digging and when we find that the
data
um you know i guess uh
conflict with what customers are saying
that it just probably
means we're missing something we're
missing the measurement of something
that's most of the time what is actually
happening and so it just teaches us how
to you know
improve our audit mechanisms in our
measurement methods and so
you know i don't think there's a silver
bullet here i think it's a maniacal
focus
um on uh you know making sure that we
can work the inputs to each one of these
branches
and that that's really i think the
spirit of of how doordash operates
yeah that's a really great insight
because it's something that's
seemingly unscalable on the surface but
it actually has been one thing that's
crucial to the way dwardash has been
successful
yeah and i think over the over time you
find that there are certain patterns
that you can actually
you know build products for or build
tools to automate but i think if you
started that way it'd be really really
difficult because
most likely you'd be automating
something that doesn't even exist
yeah i think we are really obsessed with
data today and
it's really good to keep that in check
and know that it's really worth it to
deliver an order once in a while i know
tony many of us have been following
doordash for a while and seeing the
wally successful ipo that you recently
had
congratulations on that by the way
thanks
big team effort i think sometimes we
forget that
doordash wasn't always a sure bat and
in fact the company almost ran out of
money by the end of 2017.
so if you could take us back with you to
that moment
the investors have soured on the
delivery space
and you had spent six months trying to
get a lead investor for the next round
and
all you heard was no what kept you going
during that time and
how do you convince the others to follow
you
yeah i i think you know again
there isn't a um a silver bullet and and
and you're right um you know doordash
had
um many ups and downs and and um and and
and we still do
i i don't think the journey to um you
know
solving some of the problems we want to
solve of you know
transforming every brick and mortar
business for example is going to happen
overnight and
and you're undoubtedly going to get your
doubters along the way
and so um you know when i think back on
some of our toughest years
i think the first is actually it really
centered around this
um value of the company in which we call
truth seeking
and um you know at the company
we tend to like to say you know bring
your data and your insights
um but but not necessarily your opinions
um and when we looked at when we looked
at um you know what was happening with
the company you know
the the data and the insights would
suggest that we had a very healthy
company
and that the products that we had been
building
were very differentiated and industry
leading
now on the flip side you're right a
business like doordash requires quite a
lot of capital in order to scale
[Music]
and you know we were effectively
operating a portfolio of markets you
know some of which were much
the majority of which were younger and
therefore not yet profitable
and so that's why we needed capital um
and and i think
um because of the transparency that we
had for
many years even prior to the difficult
moments that doordash had i think people
in the company knew that
um there was a disconnect between you
know what was actually happening
with our customers and the growth of the
business and maybe
what some outsiders had written about us
or thought about us
i think that that was important i think
just being transparent with information
which was something that happened far
before i think we had difficult
moments than than than um when the
difficult moments inevitably came
and then i think the second thing was um
um
you know there isn't uh there isn't
anything you can you know
fully do to control this um in terms of
what external
you know validation or lack thereof you
know hits you
but for us it was this value of you know
choosing optimism and building a plan
you know we were prepared for pretty
much any scenario
um regardless of of what amount of
capital was going to come into the
company
i think by demonstrating that um not
just to
you know a small group of people at the
company but really to pretty much
everyone at the time i think people had
confidence that
regardless of which way you know things
were going to go
um in in terms of you know what was
going to happen externally
that um we would find a way out of it
and
and and so i i think that's the best you
can do sometimes
um because you don't get to control uh
everything when you're not yet
profitable as a company
um and and so i think the uh
the second best thing um when you don't
have full control
is that you plan for the variance
and whether that's up variance or down
variance
you should be prepared you know whether
that means it's difficult to raise
financing or whether
a global pandemic hits and and i think
those are the things that are
really really important when the tough
moments come i love
your choice of wording which is you can
choose optimism
and i think that sometimes we tend to
forget that because of
the outside validation though that we
inevitably crave that
we forget that it is actually something
we can consciously
have and then just focus on doing what
is right to move forward
yeah i think it goes both ways right and
when things are going really really well
you should also make sure you're
truth-seeking
because you're never as good or as bad
as people say you are and i think that
you know maybe the customer information
is probably the most telling
but even that sometimes you know can can
be um
you know swayed by by macro events like
a pandemic for example so i think
um it's really important to be
intellectually honest and i think if you
can do that
and if you can set that at the beginning
of your journey if you're
you know building a team or building a
company over time
i think that lays the foundation to
carry
you through the really difficult times
and
speaking of things going really well
after that difficult period for you
doordash again was on this trajectory of
rapid growth where
if i remember the numbers correctly i
think doordash's market share grew from
17 to 50 in just two years
which that kind of grows it is just
crazy
and so for you personally how did you
make sure that
you could constantly learn and adapt as
the ceo
yeah i i think it's always focusing on
the inputs not the outcomes you know in
some ways
much of the you know performance or the
outperformance of the company
came in many years before i think when
you saw some of the results
um the way i like to explain to things
you know usually
everyone when you know you started we're
all born with zero market share
um and you don't tend to just you know
do that overnight um there's probably
lots of other things that were happening
that maybe had not yet you know um
demonstrated the fruit yet
of the progress because i think this is
the hardship about um
you know starting a company really or
really frankly doing anything
that will take a period of time which is
you know what you do today
may or may not pay off right away and i
think
um your ability to um
i think articulate that to those around
you
that is really important and i think the
best way to make sure that you're
[Music]
i guess uh you know on the right path
is to look at the inputs um because the
outcomes may not always be there every
month or every week
um and and so you know at doordash
um you know for us it's always been
about improving the selection
that we offer customers the quality of
the delivery in terms of our timeliness
and our speed
um and our accuracy as well as the
affordability of the service
um you know that's what we were focused
on we weren't looking necessarily at
outcome metrics per se we were looking a
lot at the input metrics
and and that maniacal focus on that was
the
bet that we made that ultimately would
translate into things that maybe others
might appreciate or care about
because at some point you do have to you
know show your cards so to speak
and make sure that maybe some of the
ideas you had would translate into real
results
um and for us i think we always
understood that
you know relationship between what we
were working on and what the outcomes
would be maybe they wouldn't happen in
the same time period
that we were working on improving the
inputs but
i think having that understanding and
then having the
patients if you will uh to keep working
the inputs
and then letting the score take care of
itself i think those are things that we
both had to solve
and as that business grow and like you
mentioned at the very top it's kind of a
different company every six months right
so um how how did you consciously think
about
adapting your leadership style and
making sure that you are still
the best person for this company for
this specific stage
yeah well i think in the beginning
it's really about learning um how to
build a product
and how to build a product that people
really want you know it took some time
to figure out
how do you actually improve these inputs
and and you're almost making tweaks
along the way
um and over time you're trying to build
a repeatable system in which you can
take that product
um to more and more segments of the
population for us that happens city by
city but for other types of
products that can happen you know maybe
customer group by customer group
something like this
um and then i think the next evolution
was really learning about skills and
different teams you know i
i never worked a day in finance before
in my life um so it's really hard to
hire a cfo sometimes
when yes i know i went to the gsb but
but
i i i you know i probably am not a
finance expert so
you know what does it mean to be a
world-class cfo
what does it mean to be a world-class
head of engineering or head of sales
this is what i mean by skills these are
not necessarily skills i had
um but these were skills that i had to
go and try to learn
from those who were the best to kind of
form my own view
of what that meant and then you know
how that might translate into a
successful um outcome in an environment
like door ashes
and then over time it's about learning
how to build systems
um because you know once there's a
sufficient number of people it's pretty
hard to just rely on your memory
or on um i guess your your your stories
to i think
allow people to make great decisions
very quickly with high quality
and so um the obsession then kind of
morphs towards
what are the mechanisms we're going to
build to allow speed
as well as the audit mechanisms that
we're going to
create to uh you know maximize quality
and and um and so i i don't think
there's necessarily
you know one set of things you have to
learn um i i think
um you know ultimately um you know the
way that i
try to measure myself is well how are we
actually doing
along these dimensions maybe it's tough
to see in a one day or one week
you know grading period but you can see
it you know i think over six to 12
months
and and you can see a year on year are
you improving um
on the product are you improving on the
skills are you improving in some of the
systems
um and then you know what kind of
morphs even over time is how do you
actually scale this culture
um that you've built um some of it
intentionally and i'm sure some of it
you know co-created
um with all the folks that are joining
the company and so i think there are
ways in which you can you know look at
rates of progress but i think it's first
and foremost recognizing what it what is
it that you're actually trying to get
better at
um because it's hard to get better at
all of those things at once um but
that's at least what i've found
in our journey thus far that's a really
good mental model to have
and tony i know you say a lot that you
really started doordash
out of a passion to help small business
owners like your mom
and today with more than 300 000
restaurants and 200 000
dashers on the platform this passion has
also really evolved into a
responsibility
so what is your vision and and your plan
for helping the local businesses and gig
workers thrive
not just during the pandemic but beyond
yeah so the goal of the company has uh
has always been more about
you know been more about food delivery
it's always been about how do we
grow and empower local economies and the
way we do that is really with two types
of products you know
the grow part of our mission is really
exemplified by the marketplace you know
that's our app and i think what
most consumers know us for um in which
we bring you lunch or dinner
or now increasingly so you know
convenience items and grocery
supplies and things like this but
there's
that's one half of the goal the other
one half of the goal
is to empower these businesses to do it
on their own this is our platform in
which we're taking products from our
marketplace
and we're giving them to merchants so
that they don't have to rely on us that
they can create their own digital
channels
so for example there are um
you know many many many you know
businesses that
actually just um they sell through their
own channel they don't necessarily
sell through doordash but they use the
dashers on our network
and the software that we've created to
facilitate their own on-demand or
same-day deliveries this is called door
dash drive
in the um event that they don't have
their own engineering teams
to create their ordering systems we have
door dash storefront that powers them
to you know create their own online
stores that will integrate into
all of their backup house systems so
that they can compete in e-commerce for
the first time
so um and and obviously you're gonna
have to do more than just logistics
um or ordering in order to actually
build a full stack service that we have
on our marketplace there's a lot of work
that that's left to go um so i
you know our responsibility i think is
not just to help
grow and build the largest local
commerce marketplace
but also to teach and actually give
these tools so that they don't have to
rely on us
one day because that's that's really
really important in order um for their
longevity
um the the um with respect to dashers
i think dashers have taught me probably
the most of any audience um
over the over the um eight years that
we've been working on doordash uh
it's been um you know so doordash has
millions of dashers
actually um every month and and it's
been um
very fascinating to see how the the vast
majority 90 percent of them
work fewer than 10 hour week um this in
many ways is a
at least in what i've observed never
have i
seen this type of you know behavior in
any um
work environment before and um
you know the vast major you know over 80
percent of them have full-time jobs of
some form and what they're looking for
is flexibility to pick and choose when
they want to work and they're looking
for
value um i think in the hours that
they're actually
i'm seeking to work on the platform and
so um
our responsibility is very very deep not
just
to taking care of um you know those
opportunities
also making sure that we can work with
everyone such as
elected officials regulators um
and anyone else interested frankly in
creating
the future of work which i think looks
very different i think in many ways
dashers on doordash look very similar to
consumers in the sense that
they value their time as much or
sometimes more
than money and and and they in effect
are choosing
um you know some of these part-time gig
opportunities
so that um they can you know save for a
project whatever that may be
whether that's you know buying a gift
for someone or
starting an orphanage or using the money
and and um buying their kids
you know something for school and so i
think
that responsibility is very very serious
and it's one where we have to
help them achieve their goals of
flexibility flexibility and value
but also um you know work with um
you know everyone else who've created
this
labor system over the last seven decades
eight decades in the
in the u.s um and change it in a way
that actually gives them also the
protections that they deserve
and so that's what we're trying to do i
think it's not going to happen overnight
it's a very important part of what we do
and it's a very important part of making
sure
that our work with merchants and our
work with dashers can continue
the following statement which is that
the vast majority of gdp in most cities
is still produced
by businesses on the streets small
medium and large and that's that's our
that's why it's so important to us yeah
you mentioned the future of work i think
in the process of transitioning to that
more flexible
kind of work it's really on us to really
think about
the dashers the gig workers that we work
with and and think
more broadly than just our business but
also how we're impacting other people's
lives so that was
a really good reminder to have
and because of the pandemic tony i think
men
all of us had to face unexpected
challenges this year so
in that spirit i have a closing question
for you before we turn to student q a
what are the principles that you rely on
as a leader
during the toughest times
well i think the first is you know to to
do the right thing which often
is probably the hard thing and um
and you know during this pandemic um the
the right
and the hard thing to do was to shelve
some of our business plans
and actually make sure that that
the community was safe that the dashers
would be safe
that merchants would have liquidity that
we can help the community any
organization that may need our help
um whether it's you know delivering
meals just children who no longer can
get them anymore because schools are
closed
um or to give healthcare workers you
know free meals because you know they're
working 24 7.
so that's the first thing the second
thing is
that you have to have a bias for action
um because you can't let the uncertainty
if you will
necessarily
i guess stop all things or stop all
activity
and most of the time that that bias for
action
means it's just focusing on what you can
control it's not trying to say
by doing this we're going to control
some outcome but by doing this that we
will have some influence
and maybe you know that work
combined with maybe you know luck a lot
of times
that that's what will yield the the good
outcome
and you know for us um for example
when we at the beginning the pandemic it
wasn't obvious to me
that even the restaurant kitchens would
be allowed to stay open
actually if you looked at what happened
across the world some countries whether
it's china
and some others like the uk actually
shut down restaurants
altogether completely including the
kitchens which meant the takeout or the
delivery
business would be stopped as well and um
those are things you have to be prepared
for and so you and
this is what i mean when i say you can't
influence that you you can work
alongside
you know governments and elected
officials on that um but but you
you can't control that outcome but you
have to be prepared for you know what
the consequences are
um i think the third thing is um
you have to trust your team um because
no one person is going to get you
through
a pen you know any sort of difficult
situation
and certainly not a pandemic you know to
give you a sense of what it felt like
doordash i mean it pretty much was 24 7
from march through june where
we had you know twice a day meetings
across probably 20 or so work streams
when you have something like that it's
not possible to know
everything and control that decision
making
and so i think a lot of this
obviously you know starts from
preparations that you made a long time
ago such as
building great people up allowing them
to make
many decisions prior to when a big
moment like this happens
um but but you have to trust the team
and you have to trust the process that
they've built
um to solve the hard problems and that's
what i'm most proud of you know when i
look back at um you know 2020 it wasn't
necessarily
you know what happened with an ipo it
was you know how we responded during
um a difficult time for everyone
that's really valuable advice and tony
thank you for sharing your grit
your scrappiness and growth mindset with
us
with that we'll now turn to student q a
i believe that
jenna is up first my question is about
cities
and how they'll evolve and so you've
mentioned a little bit about the future
of work about sort of changing
regulatory environments i'm curious how
else do you see cities evolving over the
next 10 years and
what is doordash's role or place within
that evolution
sure well you know the first thing i
would say is i think cities are always
going to get better
i mean i i think um i forget uh who
studied this maybe
um i'm gonna blank on the author but
um but but cities have been one of the
most enduring
i guess organizations that have ever
made it through the history of time you
know far more enduring than businesses
have and and i think again
you know i mentioned earlier that most
of gdp
still happens inside local communities
you know i think in the us that's
north of 50 that number has been true in
pretty much every decade that it's been
measured
and um i think it shows you the
resilience of how cities go through
you know obviously economic cycles as
well as even you know pandemic cycles
i'm very optimistic
and i think you know what you're going
to see is i think you're going to see
more consistency
across cities i think we used to maybe
think oh well
you must live in a certain city in order
to access certain things you must live
in new york city to access
delivery you must live in san francisco
to work in
technology i think you're going to see
more of that spread
you're going to see a greater
distribution of all the things that i
think we each want you know convenience
for example or access to different types
of jobs
in more places and and this kind of
growth of almost hubs if you will of
all the things that because we're all
human we all want similar things at the
end of the day
um i think it's going to be more
consistent
not less consistent um and so i i think
our role
is to play our small part in making sure
that we can
make every small medium and large
business you know brick and mortar
business
make this transformation from doing
pretty much everything from customer
acquisition to customer service
inside stores to a world where they do
this
also with digital channels and so
um i think we have a long ways to go um
and
but we're excited about the journey
ahead and what other industries or
verticals could you see
doordash's last mile fulfillment model
be a pl
be applied well and why
sure well um again crawl walk run as i
like to say
um and it's it's it's tough doing one
thing well
and and so as you kind of go forward you
want to sequence that appropriately but
uh well one of the reasons why we
started with um
there are a few reasons why we started
with restaurants um you know one of the
reasons why we started with restaurants
was um you know if the goal ultimately
is to bring you everything inside your
city
um in minutes not hours or days we
thought it would um
make sense to start with what we had
guessed to be the highest frequency
category first
so that we can have lots of activity
because when you have lots of activity
in the same geography you have um
basically the the greatest density of
work if you will the greatest density of
work is what allows you to be more
efficient
and also achieve a lower cost
way of bringing things to places the
other reason why we started with food
is um we knew that something like
restaurant food is very perishable
obviously
you have minutes to get this right and
if you get it wrong you kind of have to
solve it then and there
you can't you know wait to you know give
you your password the next day or
something it's not like that
you kind of have to solve it there and
then and so
um we thought that if we can tackle the
hardest problem first
that other categories at least from a
pure um
last mile logistics perspective um would
would be easier to do obviously if you
have more time to deliver something less
perishable that's easier
than more time pressure and greater
perishability and so
um you know for us you know we found
that to be true as as
now we're starting to deliver
convenience items from places like
cbs walgreens 7-eleven as we're
delivering grocery items from places
like smart and final or
meyer hyvee and other places um that
that that seems to be true
but we have a lot of work to do i mean i
think one of the hardest things of what
we have to do is we have to digitize the
physical world
um there does not exist for instance
some easy structured catalog
where you know how long it takes to bake
a deep dish pizza
versus making a salad or how many apples
are left in aisle six
or what are the prices for this item as
they are changing
maybe by the hour um by certain stores
because of a promotion or something like
that
and so um or i mean i know we're in a
pandemic but post pandemic where's the
last
you know parking space in san francisco
or los angeles i mean these are tricky
questions
um where we first have to almost study
the world first
um before we start um hopefully you know
bring value to different people inside
that world so
that's still a big part of the journey
for us right now
but i'm confident that you know based on
where we started
that that gives us quite a lot of
opportunities to deliver everything else
thank you both for the questions tony
i'd like to wrap up with a custom review
from the top lightning round
i think we have maybe 30 seconds left so
i'll be quick
um it's only three questions the first
question is
what is your favorite class of the gsb
i i don't know if it's taught anymore um
it was called
i think it was called aligning startups
in their markets taught by andy
ratcliffe
um and mark leslie i don't know if that
class is still there but
that was um that was a highlight and
what is your go-to food delivery order
oh actually i don't have one so
my my my wife and i we actually try a
different place
um uh almost every time when we were so
we've ordered from about 1100 places so
far
in the bay area i guess the most recent
order
was a um a new sushi place
that we discovered in san francisco
called sasa japanese restaurant
nice last question in just one sentence
what would be your
word of advice for aspiring
entrepreneurs at the gsb
well if you're an aspiring entrepreneur
i i i i would say
find something you're obsessive about
and um
that's and and then um that's where i
would start
because um you know the journey to
building anything
of um meaning i believe will take
years maybe decades and so i think
unless you are
maniacally focused on it i i think it is
difficult
um to maybe make it all the way through
all the um
ups and downs and so find something find
something that you're obsessive about
with that tony it's been truly a
pleasure thank you again for joining us
of course thanks for having me
you